Tristan Thompson gushes over Khloe
Kardashian on her birthday and were not
really sure how to feel about it the NBA
star took to Instagram on Wednesday with
a positive blessing for his ex on her
35th birthday sharing this sweet photo
of Khloe holding their one-year-old
daughter true along with the caption you
were the most beautiful human I have
ever met inside and out thank you for
being an amazing mommy to our princess
true she is blessed to have someone like
you to look up to the 28 year old
athlete continued writing I wish you
nothing but more success adding enjoy
your day Koko in case you're not up to
speed on the backstory Koko and Tristan
broke up earlier this year after he
allegedly cheated with Kylie's bestie
jordan woods it's just you know things
happen now fans are watching Khloe deal
with the fallout from the scandal in the
two-part Keeping Up with the Kardashians
season finale
Jordan never once has Jordan said I'm
sorry I'm sorry
but when et chatted with Jordan at the
launch of her second design
collaboration with boo Hakam on
Wednesday she was singing a slightly
different tune of course I'm sorry and
apologetic as much as I can be in you
know yes say about where your
relationship is now
hmm I don't think that really matters
right now the same day Coco took to
Instagram with a cryptic message as
she's been known to do quoting the
famous song can't help falling in love
Chlo posted wise men say Only Fools Rush
in followed by the caption but I can't
help falling in love with you could she
be talking about her ex-boyfriend / baby
daddy we'll have to wait and see through
this all Coco is keeping things positive
here's what she told ET this week I
don't think there needs to be negativity
on anywhere I think it's just a story
that's being told but anybody picking a
side or you know condemning any human I
think this is a part of life I'm not
saying it wasn't in it yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]